is Barack Obama a gay crackhead he is
according to Larry Sinclair a recent
guest on Tucker's show who claims to
have first hand as it were knowledge of
Obama's proclivity
for both drugs and Friends of Dorothy
you're just a guy who's in town for the
night and it sounds like you're looking
to parties yeah hold up in a bar outside
and there's this guy that's introduced
to me as Barack Obama I had given Barack
250 dollars to pay for Coke I start
putting a line on a CD tray to snort and
next thing I know he's got a little pipe
and he's smoking so I just started
rubbing my hand along this thigh to see
where it was going and it went the
direction I had intended it to go even
though you had sex with him twice you
did cocaine with him watch them smoke
crack twice you had no idea who he was I
had no idea who he was enthusiastic the
obvious question what was Obama like on
crack
um is it your sense that that sewer bomb
is just transactional or the he's
bisexual or like what is this it
definitely wasn't barack's first time
and I would almost be willing to bet you
it wasn't as long
the guy's running for president and
credible information comes out that he's
smoking crack and having sex with dudes
that seems like a story well it would be
a story of the media really cared about
telling people the truth
now I'm not saying the man is credible
but I will say
he sounds a lot more credible than
Christine blasey Ford who accused
Justice Brett Kavanaugh of trying to
rape her when they were 15 or something
he sounds a lot more credible than that
Bergdorf Goodman lady who said that
Trump ravished her in a department store
dressing room in both of those cases
their stories kept changing and in the
case of Ford there's no evidence she
ever even met Kavanaugh
in the case of Larry Sinclair he's been
keeping his story straight but not
exactly straight obviously but is his
story consistent since 2007 which raises
another question
Larry Sinclair has been telling his
story since 2007.
so why are people only talking about it
now
in part you might say
it's because Obama's long out of office
so the media no longer feel the need to
protect him maybe
but the media still love Obama they
still carry water for him all the time
that's not why this conspiracy theory is
finally being discussed more seriously
what's changed is not how the media view
Barack Obama what's changed is how we
view conspiracy theories since so many
of them have come true
today unlike in 2007 we know that there
actually is an elite pedophile ring
comprising some of the most prominent
people on earth
they even have their own Island we've
seen the pictures of it we know that the
virus that served as a pretext to shut
down the world almost certainly did leak
from a biolab contrary to what we were
told at the time that was a conspiracy
theory remember we know that the
measures imposed on us to fight that
virus were pretty much all bogus
ineffective when they weren't outright
harmful and intentionally dishonest
we know that the doj used made-up
evidence to spy on Donald Trump's
campaign we know that the FBI just this
past year was spying on Catholic
parishes and then lying about it we know
that the CIA had a relationship with
John F Kennedy's assassin we even now
know that they actually were turning the
freaking frogs gay
so is it really such a stretch to
believe that the defeat politician who
admitted in writing his penchant for
cocaine and homoerotic Fantasies might
have done some weird drug and sex stuff
with the guy in Chicago
I'm not saying I believe it
but at this point
there is very little that would surprise
me I'm Michael knowlesus the Michael
null show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
right now you can go to goodranchers.com
use my code Knowles kwles for 30 bucks
off any box promo code Knowles Canada
wlas goodranters.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered
the libs the Wiley Coyote Libs they're
trying to get Trump again this time a
liberal group is filing a 14th Amendment
lawsuit to keep Trump off the ballot in
Colorado because you know Trump he could
never win no one would ever vote for
Trump that's why they're trying to take
him off the ballot we'll get to that in
just a moment first though
speaking of male camaraderie
the Liberals are throwing the proud Boys
in prison for decades
these are people who
walked around the capitol on January 6
the worst day in the history of the
world the day when the light of
democracy was almost snuffed out forever
uh these are people who
I'm not saying they didn't make a
nuisance of themselves I'm not saying
they weren't a little bit Rowdy but
compared to what the Liberals have done
the environmental activists the BLM
activists santifa compared to those guys
who have Nary gotten a slap on the wrist
uh what the proud boys and the rest of
the January Sixers did is Child's Play
and they they had the book thrown at
them while the BLM rioters who who
burned down cities who killed people who
looted for coast to coast many of them
were dismissed even without a warning
you know they just had the charges
dropped the proud boys now are going to
prison for what 10 years 17 years in the
case of the leader Enrique Taria who
wasn't even in DC on January 6th he's
got 22 years in prison for the seditious
conspiracy to
I don't know go take a photo with Nancy
Pelosi's lectern I don't know the
seditious treasonous conspiracy the very
near coup d'etat that involved cracking
a Coors Light in the capital rotunda
these must be the worst insurrectionists
in the history of America because they
didn't bring any weapons I don't know
what they thought was going to happen I
don't know what the Liberals thought
that the supposed insurrectionists were
going to do but more is coming out about
the proud boys
the Liberals hate the proud boys they
say they're the worst terrorist group in
America and the Daily Star
has found out about the proud boys
initiation rituals
and they say these are the far-right
prad boys sick initiation rituals strict
rules concerning depraved sexual acts
that one performs alone and violence
that's okay the sick initiation rituals
the the strict rules around sexual acts
okay well what are they
what are they this is what the Liberals
find so repulsive horrific terrifying
that they've got to
lock these guys away for two decades
these are the sort of things which I'll
read in a second they're going to keep
you up at night unless you have a helix
mattress right now go to helix.com
Knowles with everything going on in the
world right now you could really use a
good night's sleep that's why you got to
check out Helix mattress the Helix
lineup offers 20 unique mattresses
including the award-winning Luxe
collection the newly released Helix
Elite collection and mattress for Big
and Tall sleepers even a mattress made
just for kids I've had my Helix for
years I absolutely adore it I sleep
magnificently and I want the same for
you Helix has a sleep quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress because why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
go to helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body type you
don't want someone else's mattress get
out of my mattress I'm a married man
head on over right now to helixsleep.com
Helix is offering 25 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners in honor of Labor Day go to
Helix sleep.com Knowles use code Helix
partner 25 this is their best offer yet
it will not last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
The Daily Star has taken a deep dive
into the proud boys downright weird
Doctrine from its Twisted rituals and
West is best mentality to its no
I don't want to say this on air
no
sex alone with yourself decree okay so
this is what they say it's weird Twisted
is it the westest best mentality so if
you believe that Western Civilization is
good perhaps better than other
civilizations that's sick that's Twisted
according to the Daily Star
nothing seems particularly out of the
blue with the first stage being to
recite the oath I'm a proud Western
chauvinist I refuse to apologize for
creating the modern world
okay this term is obviously
tongue-in-cheek is the word chauvinism
comes from Nicola Chauvin this French
soldier maybe legendary French soldier
who was gutted and chopped up and torn
up and killed so many times for the
French army but he kept going out there
to fight you know nothing could possibly
stop him from the battle so it's it's a
term that refers to excessive
love and pride and uh it's it's a
caricature in itself and the proud boys
being a fraternity for older fellas you
know a fraternity for guys in their 30s
uh obviously take part in this kind of
hyperbole so that that's obviously
hyperbole I refuse to apologize for
creating the modern world frankly if
there's anything that I object to in the
proud boys uh initiation ritual it's the
refusal to apologize for making the
modern world because the modern world is
pretty messed up but anyway obviously
this is just a almost entirely
unobjectionable sentence next a group of
helmet wearing thugs Pummel The Pledger
until they can name five breakfast
cereals
hazing this is just
this is just what they do in
fraternities
it's not they're trying to make this out
as some kind of dark insane you know
skinhead Neo-Nazi group this is the sort
of thing that you do freshman year in
college when you're initiated into a
fraternity and the guys come out and
they're kind of beating you up a little
bit and they say you gotta say come on
Fruit Loops Cheerios come on oh I can't
it hurts come on guys this is really
really basic stuff
and of course writes the daily Story
You've Got to Be an alpha male and
renounce the cancer of feminism
yeah feminism's a cancer it's awful it's
ruined Society it's it's the cause of a
number of social problems it's also a
symptom of some social Decay it's made
women miserable It's Made Men miserable
yeah
total common sense then being a man
requires four things the group's
original founder Gavin McGinnis
previously said you have to have had a
broken heart you have to have you have
to break someone's heart you have to
beat the out of someone and you
have to have the beaten out of you
that's pretty much true to it's sad that
that is the process of becoming a man
if you can avoid breaking someone's
heart if you can it's bad to break
someone's heart so avoid it if you can
it's a fallen world and most of us do it
if you can I guess avoid having your
heart broken but you're not going to be
able to do that
if you can avoid beating the out of
someone but maybe you're going to have
to sometimes you got to stand up for
yourself and it is a part of growing up
to get the beaten out of you
figuratively literally or both usually
both
once you've had the proud boys tattoo
etched on your arm
then you pop on the uniform which
consists of a black and yellow Fred
Perry polo shirt so even even the
uniform is kind of ironic and a little
bit hipster and it's just a plain it's a
polo shirt it's just a shirt that normal
people wear it's not it's not a clan
robes with a hood with a pointy hat it's
not you shave your head it's you just
wear a polo shirt and you act like a
normal guy the rule book reads this is
the one that they really got upset with
no heterosexual brother of the
fraternity shall
we say stimulate himself more than one
time in any calendar month uh self
stimulation
is a lack of impulse control one member
told SBS Dateline if you control your
impulses you can control and regulate
most aspects of your life so the the
Liberals are now are complaining that
the proud boys don't want you to be a
wanker that's it that's it that how
perverse is our society that when guys
come around and say like hey dudes
control yourself control your appetites
don't be a lame loser wanker sitting
alone in your room looking at
pornography like get some control over
your life and stop being a weirdo and a
pervert that when when guys just give
that advice which was the advice that
all teachers of virtue taught for all of
human history the Liberals come in and
say no you have to go look at porn go
into your closet
do depraved sexual acts so so pathetic
if you're thinking of getting high
heroin and Crystal math are absolute
no-nos however you can indulge all you
like in cocaine so there are I don't
know what what are the Liberals upset
about here that the proud boys are
saying you can do Coke or the proud boys
are saying that you can't do heroin in
crystal meth because what I hear from
the Liberals is we need to legalize all
these drugs we need safe syringe
shoot-up areas we need to turn San
Francisco into one big crack Den one big
sorry one big heroine Dead one big
fentanyl then
so they're the proud boys are at least
saying hey guys do fewer drugs than you
might otherwise be inclined to do and
outside the realm of Narcotics also band
is wearing flip-flops fedoras or cargo
shorts to any proud boys Meetup
great I don't what's the problem here
I don't the chauvinism line is
hyperbolic but it's kind of funny I
don't I'm not a big tattoo guy
I think one time a month for that thing
that they tell you not to do is too much
also and I I would generally discourage
cocaine
but the proud boys initiation rituals
by and large are are not so bad
actually the proud boys initiation
rituals are much healthier than the
initiation rituals pushed by our broader
culture our broader culture has
initiation rituals too all cultures do
and what are the initiation rituals for
us it's to
go to college and be brainwashed and
told to hate your parents and your
country and to become a huge lib if not
an outright communist your initiation
rituals involve tons of promiscuous sex
looking at a bunch of porn doing a bunch
of drugs dressing like a slob being told
that men are evil uh being told that
your country is evil being told that if
you're a white person heaven for fend
you're definitely evil being to
those are all bad those are bad
initiation rituals and they are
ubiquitous in our country and they start
at age four they start at age three
forget about them starting at age 25 or
whenever people join the proud boys
it's not a defense of the if I were
running the proud boys I'd probably do
things a little bit differently but but
you say this is the great threat to our
country
compared to the the other groups in our
country including the the mainstream the
elite the ruling class these guys are
downright wholesome
so because of that they've got to lock
them away for 22 years speaking of
rituals young people face
covet is coming back I've mentioned this
for a while it's right on time because
the election is one year away
and some people deny this they say I
don't know Michael I don't think it's
really going to come back I think you're
just a little paranoid well
you are denying that we are about to
enter phase one of the covid come back
covid 2.0 Electric Boogaloo
we're already in phase three phase one
was when Lionsgate and Hollywood started
to re-implement the mask mandates that
was the little test
how are these headlines going to work
there was a strike going on at the time
so Hollywood was basically shut down it
was a it was an easy test are people
going to accept these masks
okay then after that we got to
a school in Atlanta
this was a college we got to a college
in New Jersey
are they going to accept this
again it's the summer that these
colleges are beginning to bring back the
mask mandates not too much risk
okay people are going along with it that
was phase one phase two was when the
White House came out and said Joe Biden
is going to mask up
some some government officials are going
to start putting the masks back on
that's a lot more public is that gonna
how's the public gonna react to that
okay the Public's basically going along
with it now we're in phase three which
is K-12 schools all around the country
are beginning to re-implement The Masks
kinterbish Junior High School in Alabama
has asked all students staff and
visitors to start wearing masks in the
classrooms to slow the spread of covid
Alabama
so we're not talking about New York and
California Alabama Talladega City School
District more than 1700 students has
urged children and staff to wear masks
Maryland elementary school has sparked
outrage after telling the students not
only to wear masks but where those n95
masks which pose certain health risks by
the way we just learned that a week or
two ago and also they're extremely
uncomfortable and they want them to do
it just for 10 days
despite only a handful of kids testing
positive for covid and despite kovid not
posing a particular threat to young
people and then New York
New York Health officials providing free
masks in schools throughout the state
as a response to Rising covid you're
seeing this also start to happen in La
we're in phase three guys
and
it's it seems so audacious it seems so
impossible to believe that they're going
to bring this back
frogs get very quickly accustomed to the
increasing temperature in the water
right it's an image that is cliche at
this point but it's cliche for a reason
because it accurately describes the
political operations we are the Frog
being boiled in water this occurred to
me because
as I saw the masks starting to come back
it I realized that I had already
forgotten about how insane covid was
they shut down our country for over two
years
pretty much just to rig a presidential
election it wasn't because the virus was
particularly dangerous it wasn't because
the the measures that they put into
place were particularly effective they
weren't in some cases they were quite
harmful they just did it to rig the
election that's why they did it when
they did it that's why they're doing it
when they do it again they haven't done
this every year
kovid's pretty much been over for two
and a half years they're only bringing
this back in the lead up to the 2024
election and it's so hideous because
our relatives died alone many people
didn't get to say goodbye to their
parents
weren't allowed to hug their loved ones
had to postpone their weddings weren't
allowed to see their babies right away
after they gave birth weren't allowed to
have funerals weren't allowed to have
Christmas I mean they they really they
really
did US dirty the ruling class and they
did it to rig an election that's that
was the maybe some of them were
sincerely worried about the virus maybe
some of them were just
exaggerating Their Fear of the virus
but the political incentive to keep this
country locked down was all about the
2020 election and this time it's all
about 2024 and the fact that it was so
egregious and it was so traumatic
and then we all just kind of forgot
about it and moved on
it just shows you how quickly
that memory evaporates and they're going
to do it again and we're and that water
is going to be boiling hot before we
know it
and already
the elected officials are going off
script
so what do we say phase two of bringing
the masks back they're going to be like
50 phases but phase two was Joe Biden is
going to start masking up again and yet
he just showed up to an event with the
press and he walks on stage
and he's not wearing a mask
now
the mask for your face is made of cloth
and is completely ridiculous the mask
for your house is made of glass it's
called a window and there are nice
window installations that you can have
around them shutters blinds all that
sort of thing and when those are very
good you need those on your house when
you want to address your home's Windows
you got to check out Renewal by Anderson
right now text Knowles to 200 300 for
most homeowners window replacement is
not something they've done before and
for many it is not something they want
to do but something they have to do if
you have put off replacing the windows
in your home because it's too expensive
well I've got great news you can now get
a free in-home window consultation and a
free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson Renewal by Anderson signature
service is committed to giving you the
best customer service possible supported
by the best people in the industry
Superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for one year text Knowles known
200 300 for your free consultation to
save 375 off every window and 750 off
every door these savings will not last
long so be sure to check it out by
texting Knowles Canada w-l-e-s to 200
300 that is nulls to 200 300. I've been
told someone wrote Into the show
contractor or Carpenter who said that
whenever he goes in and sees homes with
Renewal by Anderson the work is so much
better than any of the competition and I
have a cousin who works for them too it
says they're great texting privacy
policy and terms and conditions posted
to textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages messaging data rates may apply
reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for the full
offer details
just a day or two after Joe Biden says
that he's going to start wearing the
masks again he walks into an event he's
not wearing a mask
explain to the Press
I've been tested again today I'm clear
across the board but they keep telling
me because this has to be 10 days or
something I got to keep wearing it but
don't tell them I didn't have it on when
I walked in
the Press laughs
but were they laughing at
They're laughing at you
that's who they're laughing at they're
not laughing at Joe Biden your mind
saying hi I said I was gonna wear a mask
but I'm not going to wear it it's okay I
don't have covet
the the only reason
that we're all supposed to be wearing
these masks is because covet is
allegedly this deadly horrific disease
that's going to kill us all if we don't
upend society and rules and regulations
and laws and individual liberties and
all the rest of it to protect against it
that shouldn't be a laughing matter when
you violate that but it is because they
know that the virus isn't particularly
dangerous and they know that it doesn't
Merit upending Society other than the
political ends that they're trying to
inflict so Biden he can choose to not
wear his mask and he probably does a lot
the Press they don't need to wear their
masks
but you do
and that's the punch line that's the
joke of it
speaking of
laughing there's a woman
I don't know if I'm allowed to get to
this bit on YouTube this part might be
cut out of YouTube so
[Music]
strong
all right my favorite comment yesterday
is from philveda3308 who says is fauci's
defense really the singular for data is
anecdote and this guy is supposed to be
one of these smart people I know I love
this when he was confronted and CNN says
look there are all these studies that
show that The Masks didn't really work
and the social distancing didn't really
work because well yes that's true in
General on the aggregate The Masks did
not stop the spread of covid but some
individuals maybe said they did you
think well hold on isn't that
you always tell us not to point to
anecdotes to point at data but when the
data are inconvenient for you you say
ignore the data just look at the
anecdotes of course
you're going to see a lot more of that
in the future now
speaking of the future of conservatism
Mike Pence
has some thoughts
here within the Republican party I think
we have a choice to make and that is
whether or not we're going to offer the
American people
a candidate and a standard Bearer that
will carry forward the common sense
conservative agenda of a strong National
Defense American leadership in the world
fiscal responsibility and pro-growth
policies a commitment to Traditional
Values and Liberties and life
or whether or not we'll follow the siren
song of populism unmoored the
conservative principle
I really like Mike Pence I think he's an
honorable guy I just think he happens to
be wrong here
what we're hearing is the same sort of
thing we heard in 2016.
which is that we've got the conservatism
which is principles and the principles
are cut taxes fund add more military
funding
x y and z
or populism
which that's Donald Trump and it's sort
of ironic coming from Mike Pence because
Mike Pence was the running mate and vice
president for Donald Trump who is
considered the face of American populism
but that word populism I'm not sure it
really means anything
as it is used it's just used as a term
of derisional this populism from the
people on the left and from the Liberals
on the right we need to cut out this
popular what is populism
populism means different things
at different times
politics is eternal principles applied
to ever-changing circumstances and
sometimes you focus a little bit more on
the principal side sometimes more on the
circumstance side and populism is is
much more sensitive to changing
circumstances but what it boils down to
is a recognition that there is a Chasm
between the people and the supposed
representatives of the people
and when the people feel like they're
being gypped and they're not actually
being represented in the government
then you're going to see Rising
populism
that that is not a siren song that's an
important alarm that's a warning sign
that something's gone wrong in your body
politic
neither party neither base group of
Voters the liberals or the conservatives
has Faith any longer in American
elections
the left has questioned way more
elections than the right has and the
right obviously is is skeptical of the
2020 election
we no longer really believe in our
system of justice the left has for years
said the system of justice is being
weaponized against racial and sexual
minorities and I I think that's largely
not not true but
the right is pointing out hold on though
the justice system is being weaponized
against conservatives and pro-lifers and
Catholics and Midwestern grannies from
January 6th and so we don't have faith
in that any longer
we say wait hold on our economy is no
longer really working for us and the
representatives so-called in the
Republican and Democrat parties are
they're all for outsourcing they're all
for sending our manufacturing overseas
they're all for free trade deals that
are supposed to boost up GDP but a lot
of people especially working-class
Americans on the left and the right are
getting squeezed here they don't feel
like they're being
represented
what is the future here conservatism or
populism ironically what is being called
populism is a much
more solid and traditional and classical
form of conservatism before the Chic
corporate
kind of libertarianism of the last three
decades took over
protect your workers build up your
industry secure your borders
that's if that's populism if that's not
conservatism then I don't know what I
guess I'm not a conservative that seems
pretty conservative and basic to me and
you have to take populism
seriously
because otherwise you could have a lot
more political instability and I and I
think the people in this case have a
real Point there's there's a good reason
why the American people don't really
have faith in elections anymore well
here's the story I'll tease it I'm such
a tease this liberal group is filing a
14th Amendment lawsuit to keep Trump off
a ballot in Colorado
if the people were being represented if
our form of government were really
synonymous with democracy right now then
no one it would would worry about Donald
Trump being on a ballot if if the ruling
class really believed that Trump could
never win a general election then they
wouldn't be trying to kick him off the
ballot because they say okay he's going
to be on the ballot he's going to get
absolutely trounced at the ballot so no
big deal move on
but that's not really what they believe
they believe that the people want to
elect Donald Trump just as they elected
him in 2016 and
who knows what happened in 2020 and they
at least fear enough that they could
elect him in 2024. despite their
protestations to the country that they
want to kick him off of the ballot
that's my tease we'll get more into that
story tomorrow all right now speaking of
the future of conservatism I'm joined by
my friend who is not allowed on YouTube
right now actually so if you're watching
on YouTube you cannot watch this
interview you got to go to dailywire.com
and you got to go to mnol's show on X
formerly known as Twitter
so here's the interview with my secret
friend
[Music]
if you are watching on YouTube you
didn't get to see that interview but you
get to go to dailywire.com right now or
mnol's show on x
but you should go to dailywire.com
because the rest of the show continues
now
[Music]